hello and welcome to this video and I'm
playing and someone pointed out to me
that is probably not you jazz huge as
and probably I didn't quite get the
intention of this handle what is so
supposed to be pronounced but anyway
okay yeah I think usually you play this
before age six because I think there is
a drawback to this there's some drawback
to this
hmm let's say c4 Knight c2 9h flagship
age 7
okay this is play C six and this is
crazy
really okay absolutely not interested in
looking at night C to win I really have
to eat breakfast and now he's thinking
about it all but what's going on my my
idea maybe it is just complete nonsense
but I was thinking after 92 I wanted to
play Knight e5 actually that's probably
complete [ __ ]
sorry but again now now his whole setup
makes no sense at all
95 maybe Bishop d7 still is playable for
black yeah but he has to do this is the
only way so how do we go about this now
it looks looks pretty awful but he
threatens Knight takes e5
and is this is now a situation where
William where you would love to have
more time see if you how to refute this
stuff when I invested some time which
was an entirely no idea or maybe this
isn't it a known sacrificial idea and
here I was some just playing his theory
in a way okay so now I want to do this
d5 then look do you want or is that
silly let's go
I wasn't even sure if he maybe can take
on de for him
this is not easy now go black
it's a nice bishop but the e-file is
just extremely important
it's all about the quickest possible
development so how to do this the other
work to you one would be beautiful maybe
just this one you threatening rookie one
you can just play that why did I not
take that into account
this is crazy
I have no clue how did he get out out of
the middle gym good nine seconds nine
seconds
the good news is that this is a fairly
simple position to play
I can take the six the whole time I just
wanted to to wait until the right moment
is is there and it's not impossible that
there was something better even than
taking it but the good point about this
is like this is now very easy to play
you're just pressing in and it's tough
tough would like to hold this if not
downright impossible
yeah it just just lost him I get to the
point to a seven move the rook and
promote I still don't get home but what
did i do there I thought I could catch
him in the middle now that makes a lot
of sense I don't want to trade
yeah so that was that was really weird
in some case and some in some way so I
have played myself this line where you
absolutely for snide a three yeah
there's absolutely no way around it in a
way and then then you can still play h6
or c6 or whatever I think I played c6 in
this position not only son oh okay he
went age six I cancelled and then he
went not before and see Frey spin move
okay okay I was thinking c4 92 95 yes
that works fantastic
okay okay and so I was writing that that
this is this is possible so 95 and I was
thinking if he takes on CA one I take d5
with the bishop and I win yes that's
true
threatening mate and I'm threatening
here and are threatening this all those
things and white wins that's nice nice
so that was not a wrong thought yeah
that at first I thought this move but I
think he can really drop back and then
I'm not certain what I do I mean the
this year I thought is probably
interesting but not not great no I will
get this Knight very likely but it's
maybe not the best so it's not full
compensation but 95 so once I saw this
idea that okay this must be right and
threatening this year so if he does this
move I think
efore is good yeah on Form yeah yeah
because here I mean this is just over
him you win this but it won't even get
to that black has blasted he in the
center so he went c6 and now I took it
now Knight see - I think I can just take
c6 I mean this
cannot work if I get to get to take here
and this 95 is also gone so he took it
and the crazy thing is that this is not
downright downright loss because I mean
it looks totally terrible and night
before back age six it's super slow but
yeah you have to play with the utmost
aggression now that's what I tried so
take it's not about the bishop AI just
you this is so the quickest way to get
pieces out ninety three four that's how
you have to play a gem and takes Knight
takes I was not totally certain yeah
exactly that's what the engine gives
Knight takes I thought that might be
playable like I have to probably take I
don't want to trade wits but I think I
have to and then I thought either work
g1 orb should be seven look t1 is not
mentioned you know u5 yeah maybe I'm
like him he gets this good control I'm
still a bit better before yeah I can
also just take b7 that is possible would
be eight and go back where you have the
bishop pair and the king is stuck okay
e6 and then D hive I mean he really
should not get out of the middle what
did i do there bishop c6 so now how do
you win this game Bishop f4 it's not bad
Oh 81 to make castles more difficult yes
that's true
that's true now if he castles this route
to D seven and okay this looks rather
bad yeah you're on the seventh day this
is week and this is this is sorry this
is coming so rookie one was city and
somehow I don't know why but okay maybe
what because I had seven seconds I
wasn't quite aware that he can just
castle okay and now you just have the
better structure but with the pants here
being weak but of course that is that is
really really not much compared to what
I had and just um I think it makes sense
what I did now to first improve and then
take he has no way to save the C point
anyway it should be three and six
because this is very bad for black this
is when he decided to to activate the
rook and trade the ape horns but that
gave me the passer immediately if you if
you stay passive I stick the rook on to
c6 and then activate the King I have
absolutely no play I think it's just
lost I cannot really do much there no
that's inaccurate okay
and whatever I mean the a pawn promotes
yeah so I think that was very
interesting opening opening phase of the
game I feel this is probably
theoretically explored but I mean I
worked it out try to work it out over
the board I was just thinking there must
be a reason why they not play this line
but it's best then actually a c6 is
actually best and he played it quickly
but if you if if this if this is his
preparation in a way why would you
prepare such a thing and it looks
terrible it's a actually something
better here Knight c3
unknown 85 first that's interesting
maybe this is even even more precise but
what I did was fine I had a huge
advantage okay guys thanks for watching